when you start a major european conflict
and get defeated you'll often lose
territory as a result in 1789 france
looked like this there was soon a lot of
warring one napoleon and just over 25
years later it looked like this not a
whole lot different and given the
destruction and embarrassment that
europe's other powers suffered at the
hands of france why wasn't it punished
more why didn't the victorious allies
carve up france so as many of you will
know france expanded rapidly in the wake
of the french revolution and peaked at
this size naturally once napoleon was
dealt with france lost most of its gains
but was allowed to keep a few conquests
that was until napoleon returned after
his second defeat france lost these
territories further the french border
regions were then occupied whilst the
congress of vienna called by the
victorious powers to decide what was to
be done with france and her allies was
ongoing it was decided that france
wouldn't be dismembered or have large
waves of land taken from it and given to
anyone else this wasn't exactly a
unanimous decision the coalition powers
fell into two groups the first was the
punish france camp this included prussia
the netherlands switzerland savoy and to
a lesser extent austria whereas the
other powers were in the let's not be
hasty camp this included the united
kingdom russia and unsurprisingly france
itself and this division was something
that the french representatives led by
charles maurice de talarant were able to
use de france's advantage prussia gained
this from the congress its original
hopes were for this but talarant was
able to convince the british and the
russians to pressure prussia to accept
these lands along the rhine which
notably included this piece of france
proper this kept the russians and the
austrians happy gave prussia some very
rich land to the west and was exactly
what the french wanted so why why
willingly give up some of your own land
because the french were convinced the
peace wouldn't last and that these lands
would be hard for prussia to maintain
meaning that in a future war france
could win them for itself this never
happened but it was an interesting idea
the netherlands and savoy were also
countries which wanted extra lands from
france the netherlands had hoped for
this but got told that their annexation
of the former austrian netherlands and
rule over luxembourg would be enough so
shut up savoy despite not doing anything
was given this land at the behest of
austria who was busy trying to create an
italian confederation much like the
german one which conveniently it would
also run except that the whole italian
confederation thing fell flat but it was
at least a good effort everyone went
along with this because the netherlands
and savoy were supposed to be mid-sized
buffer states to keep france contained
and so the only other state that wanted
french land was switzerland which had
hoped to be given all of this they only
got this connecting geneva to the rest
of the country and the reason was that
they had no major powers on their side
since none of them would gain anything
from an expanded switzerland and so what
about the rest well for the uk russia
and to an extent austria there was one
primary concern the balance of power and
maintaining monarchical government in
europe austria wanted a strong france to
counter prussia and britain russia
wanted a strong france to counter
prussia austria and britain and britain
just didn't want to have to deal with
the continent anymore and carving up
france meant that no one would get what
they wanted because if france lost a lot
of territory its recently restored
monarchy would probably be overthrown
again it's also the reason why during
napoleon's return the coalition didn't
declare war on france but on napoleon
the restored king of france was an ally
against napoleonic and republican ideals
and thus stealing all of his land
afterwards wouldn't have been cool in
the end it was the coalition suspicions
of each other that meant that france
needed to remain strong and unified
meaning that unlike in the wake of other
great wars in europe major territorial
losses were off the table
i hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons james
bisonette kelly money maker skye
chappelle corso wolff jerry lamden
jordan longley adam stalter marcus
arsenault wyan hockey spencer lightfoot
rod d martin words about books podcast
captain cydog gustav swan marvin cassell
common yoon winston k would be gilly
wiggly daniel to be in miss izzette
matthew shipley aaron the white corey
turner the mcwhopper alex schwinn
anthony beckett coppertone maggie
patzkowski schwennin spinning three
plates and charles the first